Bro, I'll literally rearrange both your
guys' faces that way.
>> I believe you, man.
>> I I know you I believe you. That's why
you're watching.
>> I believe you. You're unhinged.
>> I know you are.
>> You're unhinged. I know you are. I know
you are.
>> Looks like people are coming on out.
Going to try to see if we could go ahead
and get a conversation. See if over
here. Let's see if we could get some
private property down.
>> How you doing?
>> Private property.
>> We heard Shakeman was here.
>> I don't know. It's private property,
bro. Get off.
>> You know Is Shakman here?
>> It's private property, bro.
>> We'll step out right here.
Is is Shakuzman here? Go ahead.
>> Is Shakuzman here?
>> You don't answer questions.
>> That's not a question. He was asking
just trying to figure out problems,
brother. You don't want no problems. I
know you want to get content.
>> We just want to talk to Shik Kubman cuz
he called us out. He told us to come
over here.
>> Cool, brother. Now's not the time.
Private property, brother.
>> Yeah, we're we're off we're off your
property, so I understand that.
>> Yeah. Yo,
>> we see
>> you see how these guys are.
>> So, you clowns waited here the whole
night. I seen you in the car.
>> Why? Why are you calling us clowns?
>> Cuz I am, bro.
>> Oh, so I thought you didn't want any
problems. We just want to talk to
Shakuza, brother.
>> Bro, bounce.
>> We just want to talk to Shika.
>> He He doesn't want to talk.
>> Yes, he does. Cuz he called us out.
>> Cool, bro.
>> He's not here.
>> Oh, yeah. He is here. He is here.
>> He's here.
>> Exactly. Cool. Go back.
>> Say that again.
>> Listen, bro. Go back again.
>> I'm going to wait outside for him.
>> He comes. Cool.
>> Yeah, I'm going wait outside for him.
So, I'm off I'm off your property.
>> Yeah, we not on the property. We good.
>> You know, we good. Cool. Cool.
>> We'll wait for him.
>> Don't worry, man. You're good. Yeah.
clowns.
>> You You see You see how the Muslims are?
You see You see the clowns?
>> Clowns. Clowns.
>> You see the clowns are They're cowards.
>> They're out here cowards. They don't
want to get cooked. They don't want
their shake to get cooked. Look at him.
Look at him cussing. He's a Muslim.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I know. Look. He's a He's a
Muslim cussing out here.
>> Look, look, look at this. Look at this.
Y'all already triggered, man.
>> Man, Jesus loves you, brother. Jesus
loves you, bro.
>> Yeah, he does.
>> Jesus loves you. Jesus loves you, man.
>> Get this on camera.
>> God bless you. We got it on camera, man.
We all We the property. We out. We're
out your way. You know what I'm saying?
You can say that all you want.
>> You can say that all you want. God loves
you, brother.
>> We're going to We're going to wait for
your weak shake. We're going to wait for
your shake.
>> I know.
>> Yeah. We're going to wait for your
shake.
>> Other ones on YouTube, brother.
>> Oh, what does that mean?
>> That's right.
>> That means you That means you love
Jesus.
>> Do you love Jesus, bro?
>> Your prophet says not to talk like this.
>> Jesus says love everyone.
>> I never said it was a good one.
>> So, we're just going to wait for Shikman
to come out here. He's a coward out here
and we're going to preach Jesus. We see
if they want to debate and it doesn't
matter. We see how the Muslims are.
They're unhinged. They like to come out
here. They talk all the mess that they
want. And that's because this is the the
religion of peace. This is the religion
of peace, right? And so when you want a
peaceful conversation,
>> when you want to have a good
conversation, a good dialogue with the
Muslims problem. Why you still life?
Ignore him. It's okay. This this is
Islam.
>> You just said you just life said you
literally just said
>> life he's one he's one of those he he he
don't exist.
>> So we want to have a good discussion
with Islam with Muslims and they're
unhinged. They don't want to have a
conversation with us about the Bible
about the Quran. They don't want to do
this. And unfortunately this is how it
is. This is how it is out here. Right.
The religion. Yep. Yep. Yep. That's
right. Get that. This is how it is here.
This is how it is. So when we're out
here, we're off the property. We're not
bothering anybody. This is how it is in
Islam.
>> Nothing but insults, nothing but
threats, nothing but being the
aggressor, right? Because they have no
truth. They can't debate. They cannot
talk. They can only try to intimidate,
try to be loud, try to yell over you.
And these will be the the same type of
dude that will call the cops.
He'll be the same dude that will call
the police on you. These same cowards.
So this is what it is. But these are the
guys that Uman has. We We not on the
property. We off the property. We out
the way. We not bothering nobody. He
said Shikman doesn't want to talk to us.
Yes, he does. He He called us out. Did
he call us out life?
>> Yeah, he did.
>> He called us out, right?
>> Called you out
>> by name, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Said said that we're running.
>> So you were in San Diego. You ran. We
came to the masjid that you're at and
you're running now. You set guards out
here to let them know that we were here
so that they can stop us from coming in.
>> I knew it.
>> You're a coward. We saw we we peeped the
whole game. That's why they were
blocking They were blocking the driveway
to come in here to make sure and they
were like checking to make sure who's
who when they're coming in here cuz they
didn't want us to come in here and
destroy Uman in front of his fans. So,
we'll wait. We'll we'll kindly wait for
a little bit and see how it goes. See
how it goes.
guys. Is Is Usman in there?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. He told us to come through, but
they they won't let us in here.
>> Uh I don't know anything about that, but
he's he like he just had an event. We
just So, he's just chilling inside
talking, taking pictures, things like
that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I don't know anything about what you
guys had planned. So,
>> yeah. He's Well, he called us out to to
have a discussion, but now it's like
it's a little
>> No, he didn't he didn't he didn't say
what he just he just told us what his
what his event would be. He just said
what his discussion,
>> bro. Don't do it when there's kids
around. I'm not with the kids.
>> The guy's been trying to Listen, bro.
I'm not here for your YouTube content.
Then why are you saying you can call me
a bad a bad
>> I'm not calling you anything. I never
said you're a good one, brother. I don't
know you and I don't care. You're not a
bad Muslim.
>> You already went to that mosque last
time.
>> I think you're I think you're a good
Muslim. Listen,
>> I think you're a good Muslim. Listen,
bro. Honestly, listen.
>> We're both I think you're a good Muslim.
>> We're both men, bro. You didn't like
someone coming up to you and talking to
your wife and saying some Don't come up.
>> No, that's not what it was. Listen,
>> it it was getting getting physical with
my wife. You're getting you're getting
the stuff wrong.
>> Listen, bro. Don't come to where my
family's at. I'm not your family.
>> Don't come to where your This is my
family. Who?
>> Bro, it's my family. I am I'm off
property.
>> No, no, no.
>> I'm out. I'm out the way.
>> Listen. In when he finishes in He'll
come He'll come talk.
>> No, we're we're off the conversation.
He's going to he's going to escalate.
Have a conversation. I'm playing with
you. I'm playing with you. He's going to
escalate
with you. I'm playing with you, bro.
It's all [laughter] I'm playing with
you. I'm playing with you. It's okay.
It's okay. I'm playing with you. Just be
chill, bro. I'm playing with you. Just
be chill, bro. I'm playing with you. I'm
not a YouTube guy, bro. That's fine.
It's okay. It's okay. I'm playing with
you. I'm playing with you.
>> It's okay, man. It's okay. I'm playing
with you. I'm playing with you.
>> It's okay, man. We over here. We're
chilling.
>> No, he didn't say a time or anything. He
just said what the event was. He made a
video saying he wants to debate God
Logic and stuff like Dom got by the way.
>> Yeah, we know. [laughter]
>> We see we see the video to meet you. You
too, brother. You, too. Um, my name my
name's Avery, by the way.
>> Yeah. But yeah, so I I came I heard he
was going to be here at this event. He's
going to be in Vegas and stuff like
that. So, I'm like, "Okay." Um, well, we
didn't want to come in and disturb,
right? So, we just waited for We
appreciate,
>> right? So, we just I wanted to see if he
would come out and we could have a
conversation. If not, we'll move on.
But, you know, that just the
opportunity. No, 100%.
>> So, I know he's just he's taking
pictures, doing his thing. You know,
there's a lot of people who did come
specifically this season.
>> Of course, of course. I I I understand.
>> We are some of those people, too. So,
>> yeah, I understand.
>> But we totally understand. So, you guys
are bouncing bounce, bro. Leave these
guys alone. Listen, bro. I'm going to
ask you politely, manto man. Bro,
listen. I'm not YouTube guy. Post it on
YouTube. Say whatever you need to do,
bro. I'm telling you straight to both
your guys' face. You guys are geeks. You
guys [laughter] are You guys are losers.
You guys do [__] on Instagram. So, you
know what I'm saying? We can put the
camera [laughter] down and we can figure
it out. Other than that,
>> why would I put the camera down when
you're this hostile,
>> brother? Hop in your car. Go home.
>> I'm not going to hop in the car.
>> You know what I'm saying? You already
came to that mosque. You pulled out a
gun.
>> What?
>> And you didn't do [__]
>> What are you talking about, bro?
>> Bro, I'm telling you, [laughter]
straight to your face, bro. There's no
cameras around there,
>> brother. Just Just be peaceful, man.
>> I'm more than peaceful, bro.
>> All right. So, then walk then walk away.
>> Stop walking away.
>> You got to then chill.
>> I'm not walking away. Don't come here.
I'm going to be right. We're going to be
right here. You're a You're
giving us more content than I could have
asked for.
>> Then you can go put it on on on YouTube
[laughter] and say, "Hey, called me. I
get to my face. It's already there.
>> I didn't do both of you guys on camera.
>> Brother, we we we love we love people
who persecute us. We're not here for
this, man.
>> We're not here for this.
>> I'm not a good
>> May Jesus bless you, brother. May he
give you peace, man.
>> Leave Jesus out. May you know Jesus
needs to be here. His peace be upon you,
brother. His peace be upon you.
>> If Jesus was here,
>> Jesus peace be upon you. Jesus's peace
be upon you. I'm asking you respect.
>> Jesus's peace be upon you.
>> I'm asking you respectfully. You thank
me respectfully though. Like come on,
man. I understand. I understand your
question.
>> They're over here. If they go on then,
you know, that's the difference.
>> Exactly.
>> My wife is right here.
>> I understand. Listen, my sister's here.
You think I wouldn't want right there,
bro.
>> I want some around my wife. And I'm
telling you straight up, bro. I don't
care. Listen, bro. I'm a man first.
Man first, bro. We don't
>> I'm a man first, bro.
>> Stay the away from
>> I appreciate you guys, man. I do. I
appreciate you guys. You guys You guys
are pretty reasonable.
>> Hostile to who you want to be, right?
>> Hostile.
>> And then you want to act like a man.
>> When When was I hostile to you,
>> bro? Now you got to Bro, I'll literally
rearrange both your guys' faces at
>> I believe you, man. I know you. I
believe you. That's why you're watching.
>> I believe you. You're unhinged. I know
you are. You're unhinged. I know you
are. I know you are. I know you are. You
came. You're unhinged, man. You guys
came to that other thing. My brother
came and put you guys in your place.
>> This is what it is, man. But hey, hey,
notice that we got the we got the Muslim
brothers who are, you know, trying to
bring peace to the situation. Got to
appreciate them for that, you know. Um,
they came respectfully and peacefully,
you know. Uh, so shout out to them for
that, man. Cuz with the with with the
other guys, they don't, right? In our
experiences, other Muslims don't step in
and deescalate the situation and stuff
like that when their Muslim brother's
tripping, you know, but uh these guys
do. I I I appreciate them.
>> They're checking their brother so that
we don't have to. [laughter]
I'm proud of you, too.
>> I'm proud of you. [laughter]
>> Is this no point,
>> brother? What's What's going on?
>> No, bro. You tell me what's going on.
I I feel like you like, you know,
>> brother, look, you want to fight us or
something? Look, have a conversation
with me. They're not going to do
anything, bro. Put the camera down.
Let's have conversation.
>> I don't I don't I'm going to be real
with you. I I don't feel comfortable
without the camera. We had a discussion.
>> Okay, cool. It's okay. I'm not going to
change his mind.
>> Listen, I'm not here to change his mind.
I'm not here to change his mind. Please
let me ask about that. It's fine. I
>> Yeah, I'll I'll talk to you.
>> What's going on?
>> Okay, so here's the issue, right? Would
you like to know what's going on? I'll
tell you. Okay. So, this is what's
happening. All right.
>> So, Shakeman and I, we have history from
all the way from California. Okay.
>> So, he came out here to to Vegas.
>> Cool.
>> He made a video
>> calling me out for a discussion.
>> Sure.
>> So, I came to this event.
>> Cool.
>> To have a discussion with him.
>> So,
>> I knew Wait, just hold on one second.
Let me figure it out. Okay.
>> So, to to make sure that we didn't
disturb the event cuz we knew that there
was an event going on. We did not. We
waited and we did not go on the property
or like or go inside with like we we
approached. Yeah. We we approached if if
we if we were able to. You said, "Hey,
this is private property. Can you get
off?" We said, "No problem." Did we
fight you on that? Exactly. We stepped
off, stepped to the side to make sure we
don't cause any problems. Right.
>> Can I say something? So that's it.
>> Do you want his number and you call him
and you guys can talk about this away
from here? If you guys want to sit down
and have speak like men, right? This is
what you guys want to do. You want to
have a discussion. Yeah. Yes.
>> And this is for your camera, right? You
want to sit down like a man?
>> Yeah.
>> Reach out to him like a man.
>> I have. He doesn't answer.
>> Hey, brother. I want to sit down and
have a conversation. This is not how men
talk, bro.
>> This is This is how he does it.
>> Hold on. This is not how men talk, bro.
Okay. I'm talking to you like a man. I
could care less here, bro.
>> Okay.
>> I I I hear I hear I hear what you're
saying. You know what I'm saying? I want
to have a man-to-man conversation.
>> Like, I was just trying to I told you,
brother, put the camera down.
>> No, brother. You was cussing me out in
the middle of that. [laughter]
>> I have to.
>> I know you don't.
>> I have to, bro. I have to.
>> You don't, though. I have to, bro.
>> Cuz I didn't cuss I didn't cuss at you.
I'm not yelling at you or anything.
>> I have to, bro.
>> All right. So, look. This This is my
This is my thing. I I would love to have
his number. Listen. Listen. I heard you
out, right?
>> I would love to have Uman's number or
communicate with him.
>> But he does not do that. He does not He
does that.
>> I'm going to get you guys in hold of
each other. You guys go and sit down and
have a man-to-man conversation without
these. And then he
>> No, no, no. We're we're gonna talk on
camera. That's that's his thing.
>> So, bro, you know what the thing is?
That what you guys are trying to do,
bro, is trying to get clicks and views.
Now, the both of you guys.
>> Would you say that for Oh, you're saying
that for
>> both of you guys, bro. Listen, if you
guys really want to discuss stuff and
you want to discuss religion and you
guys want to figure it out, bro. Right.
At the end of the day, bro, I'm sure
you're not going to change your
religion. Yeah.
>> Correct.
>> I'm not going to change my religion.
>> Never say never.
>> Listen, at the end of the day, I'm never
I'm never right. Am I? Oh, sure. You're
right. I can't say. I don't know what's
in God's hands. Okay, brother. Sure.
Okay,
>> cool, bro. If you guys are trying to
have a discussion, what's the purpose of
the discussion?
>> Mhm.
>> And if the purpose is not like, are you
guys trying to understand each other?
You guys are trying to prove a point.
>> Sorry.
>> Right. And what's the point?
>> We're having a discussion for no reason.
>> Let me tell you
>> what's the reason.
>> Okay. So, the reason is is because
Shikman is very known. We all know this.
He's very known for his arguments
against Christianity. Right. Cool.
>> I'm known for my arguments against
Islam.
>> Cool.
>> We come together. We're two debaters.
>> Millions of people are going to see this
later on.
>> And where people are going to learn from
our conversation.
>> Cool.
>> People are going to pick out whatever
they want to. They sit down and learn.
We'll get some honest people. They'll
pick their, you know, what arguments
work.
>> That that's the purpose of these things
to bring people to the truth and
understand.
>> We're trying to basically try to get
people to pick a side on what you
>> We're trying to bring to people to the
truth.
>> Sure.
>> Okay. Yeah, at least my that's at least
my my my
>> Now, let me ask you a question, bro.
>> Okay. Are you a man?
>> I am a man. Yes.
>> Okay, cool. Do you think this is the
right way to handle it, bro?
>> I think it's the best way I can with
what I got. Notice I'm not on I'm not on
the property. I'm not barging in. I'm
not disrespecting you. You know,
>> bro, look, I patiently waited,
>> bro. Like, I'm being fair, right? Like,
this is some geekit, bro.
>> Why? Why do you think,
>> bro? It's geek. It's nerd. You're like,
bro, I can tell like even if if that's
what he does, bro, I'll tell him
straight to I think he's a nerd, too.
>> Then tell him. I will.
>> No, I want you to do it.
>> You're fine. [laughter] If this is what
you guys are doing, you guys are nerds,
bro. And I'm looking you say say that
about
>> I'm saying, bro, if this is what you
guys are doing for YouTube and
Instagram, you guys are nerds, bro.
>> Would you So you would agree that you
said you would say that to your face.
>> Would you say the same about to his
face,
>> bro? You're This is geekit, bro.
>> To
>> Bro, to all to everyone. You guys are
nerds, bro.
>> Okay,
>> bro. If you guys are trying to reach out
to people, go try to reach out.
>> At least at least you're being
consistent.
>> You're a nerd, bro. At least you're
being consistent, too.
>> I I agree. He's a
>> Yeah, he's a geek.
>> He's definitely a geek.
>> You're a geek, too.
>> Me?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm I'm a little bit I'm a
little bit more I'm a little bit more
fresh than him.
>> No, bro. You're You need You're
>> See, you say See, you're saying you're
talking about respectively, but you're
all you're just you're just insulting,
>> bro. Exactly.
>> It's It's It's like you It's like you're
trying to in incite something.
>> No, no, I'm not. That doesn't matter to
me.
>> Disrespecting to your But I love you,
man. I love you. I love And like a man,
I love you today. I came like a man, I
love you.
>> And I came in sold to you.
>> I love you. I love you. That's That's
not what men, [clears throat] bro. Men
don't do that.
>> That's what they do, bro. That's
exactly. So, now take a look at what a
man does when he wants to try to do
something.
>> I think I think a man I think a man a
good man is going to end a conversation
when it seems like the other guy is
getting a little emotional.
>> I never said I was a good man.
>> All right. So, I'm I'm going to go ahead
and relax this conversation. I respect
that you came over here and but you were
disrespectful. So, I'm going to go ahead
and end this conversation respectfully.
>> You're a geek, bro.
>> Okay.
>> You're a geek.
>> Whatever you say. It's all good, bro.
You don't have to tell me, brother. I'm
the one keeping it.
>> So then you shouldn't be You shouldn't
be cussing at us and threatening us.
>> I just Bro, listen. Go get it for your
clip. You got
>> You're cussing at us and threatening us.
And we're not we're not on your mind.
>> For 3 hours. I've been sitting here
watching.
>> Yes. And we respectfully waited for the
event to end.
>> He's a geek, bro.
>> So even even the other brothers can
understand like we're we're chilling
here.
>> The guy who always on the
>> Bro, you said watching on the debate.
>> Always on the debate.
>> You said chief. Yeah.
>> What do you mean? What do you mean by
that?
Guys, it's you're not doing anything
like
him. They had their own thing.
>> He wasn't necessarily invited directly,
but you were here. You know, he was open
invitation to debate him. That's what it
was. You came here in hopes to see.
What's the issue?
>> Uh there's no issue.
>> So, welcome to
>> No. Yeah. We're we're off we're off
this. We have no issue. No violence. We
we we want to meet mom. We want we want
to meet his mom. Go away, bro. She's not
going to We want to wait to see if we
can get talk with mom.
>> Meet the brother. You're not going to
meet the
>> Why don't Why don't you think that?
>> Because I'm telling you, brother. No,
I'm just
>> Yeah. Go tell his mom we're out here. Go
tell him. Walk away, brother. To come
cook us.
>> Tell
How about this? We can figure this out
cuz we not about to be over here arguing
with y'all. I'm not going to argue, man.
If you could just ask this public.
>> Does he want to be honest? Is he able to
come out and talk to him? If not, bro,
then we not going to be sitting here
arguing with y'all.
>> There's no like cutting lines of this
whole thing. I'm not trying to make
anyone mad and it's a long line to talk
to him right now.
>> It's good, bro. We going to leave. If if
if they say that Usman don't want to
talk to us, then we we going to go. We
going.
>> I'm not going to speak for him. All this
back and forth arguing with each other.
Bro, we not we're not here to do all
that. I don't know if he's going to come
out talk or not behind the camera. Fair
enough. I don't even know if he knows
you're here. I'm sure he's about to find
out to some degree. At the end of the
day, at the Look, at the end of the day,
I think I think he might know each
other. We don't need to be arguing. All
right. So, that's
a lot of [snorts] it's a lot of things
that took place out of context.
>> Bro, listen. If you want at the end of
the day, bro, come talk without the
camera. Come here.
>> I agree that that I agree with that. You
come, you put your phone down. Hey, bro.
We want to discuss this guy. He came and
talk. Hey, bro. He doesn't want to talk.
Then you go like this. Okay, bro. Cool.
>> I I agree with that. That's why I just
uh uh we want to talk.
>> No, but that's that's not the case
though because you got to go do it. But
you got
>> He's going to say this. Muslims are Let
me respond. Nerds, bro. Brother, let me
respond for a second. Let me No, no. You
see how you see how you What is going
on? No, I'm going to tell you
actions of some
you you guys were clearly reasonable.
You guys were peaceable. You guys have
come respectfully. I appreciate you
guys, man. Cuz Yeah. So, we know there's
we have both on our side.
>> There's good and bad in every culture,
right? And then the good and bad you
guys forget about, bro, not on camera,
right? Cuz the good and bad, right? Bro,
the cameras, it's not going to do
anything, right? It's not going to save
you from anything, right? Look, at the
end of all the
>> I don't know what you're talking about.
At the end of the day,
you also have to understand that this is
what they do. Bro, all I'm saying is I
agree with
>> you got to stop talking to this dude.
>> You agree. Arguing is unnecessary. So if
he won't come out, then we out of here.
Look, let's just have a sense of
reality, right? Cuz there's a sense of
reality, brother. I know what you do for
this, dude. At the end of the day, bro,
we're not about to sit here and they all
come out. Now look, there's a sense of
reality. No point sitting here.
>> I agree. Do you think we should leave?
>> Listen. All right, we can go. What's the
point? It's okay. Ain't no point sitting
here.
>> Hey, so hey, I I appreciate you, man. I
appreciate you.
>> Thank you. You see, brother,
>> brother, I appreciate you, man.
>> You guys good?
>> Good.
>> Uh, yeah. Yeah, we're fine. We we we ate
a little bit before coming here. Thank
you, man.
>> Appreciate that.
>> Yeah. Appreciate Appreciate you guys,
man. You guys are good.
>> We ended up with a a little bit later,
bro. Let him know we were here.
>> You guys are from out here.
>> You guys You guys talk do religious
talks or anything like that?
>> No, really. We're just students of the
the religion.
>> For sure. For sure. Okay. For sure. All
right.
>> We're not up there yet.
>> Well, know it's all good, man. Yeah.
Keep learning, man. For sure. Well, God
bless you guys, man. Y'all take care.
All right.
All right, ladies and gents. So, it was
made clear to us. You too, man.
>> All right.
>> It was made clear to us that Uman did
not want to talk and come out. Um, he
knew he knew we were here, which is
awesome. Let's get into this car and see
what what we get here and going
to be sitting up there with all them
talking crazy to me like that. I'm cool.
I'm good off that.
>> You don't know where I'm from. You ain't
going to just be sitting up there
talking to me any kind of way. And I
don't know who you is.
>> I'm cool.
>> Oh man.
>> I don't know who he thought he was
talking to.
>> What? What a time, man.
>> They want us to The thing is they want
us to do something. So then it's our
fault. They want to They trying to b
>> He's trying He's trying to Yes. He's
trying to antagonize.
>> That happened last time. That's why I
said from last time when that happened,
if they want to come out acting weird
like that, then we out, bro.
You don't need to talk to shake man.
Bro,
>> who who is he?
>> You don't need to talk to him, bro.
>> Yeah,
>> this this is evident enough right here,
bro. It's getting too serious. Yep.
>> We talk about God. We debate religion.
We not in here to be doing no street
stuff. I'm really from the streets. I'm
from the hood, bro.
>> I'm not I didn't do I didn't jump into
this with you to be feeling like I'm in
the hood again. [laughter]
>> I'm good off that. We out. What is he
talking about, bro? M. So it was it was
made it was made painfully clear guys um
that Usma didn't want to didn't want to
speak to us. Um
sent sent his thug out sent his thug out
to try to intimidate cuss us out put him
in front. And this is how guys remember
we we mentioned this in the beginning of
the stream. We knew that they knew
>> called the police too. He even said it
too. He told him to call the police on
camera. incredible
>> to he he he knew that we was out here.
He knew that we was here and um put his
goons out in the front. The most
unhinged one at the front.
>> Can't even talk to him.
>> He can't even talk to him.
>> He don't know if he want to be cool or
mean.
>> Most unhinged dude um out there. Um man
doesn't want to talk. You're a coward,
dude. Now, let me say this for the
record. Shout out to the two young
Muslim brothers who were trying to
deescalate the wild brothers. One wild
one and then the other one that just
started talking crazy.
>> Mhm.
>> We didn't have to say we didn't have to
say anything because the two other
brothers was pulling their brother the
the crazy one away and you know telling
the other brother to watch how they're
talking and stuff like that. So shout
out to those two young brothers who were
trying to who were mature enough to and
respectful enough to deescalate the
situation. So, if you guys ever see this
uh YouTube, man, shout out to you guys.
Um, it was nice meeting you guys. But my
goodness, we Hey, we tried. Can't say we
can't say we didn't try. Um, you are one
of the biggest cowards of all time.
You're one of the biggest cowards of all
time. Don't you ever ever say that
anybody's running from you. You are a
coward. Came to your event. I went to
your dollar booth. You ran away. You
knew I was going to be there 2 weeks
ahead of time. I came to your event. You
knew I was here. You put your goon in
the front to stop me from coming. You
are a coward. Um man, you are a coward.
We showed up to your events. We showed
up to your booth. You are nowhere to be
found. You are a coward. A you're worse
than a female dog. Don't ever say any
Christian is running from you ever
again. You're nothing. So IP Dwood, all
of you guys, no more Shake Guan stuff.
He's done. It's over. He's a He's
officially an absolute coward and a
victim. We don't need to do the videos.
We don't need to do the trading the live
and and fake setting up stream. We don't
need to do none of that. We pull up
straight up
on King David. [laughter]
Straight up. So, with that being said,
in our wisdom, going to go ahead and
take off and uh enjoy the rest of our
night. Um,
I'm going to get home, see what the
wifey's talking about. And if if you
know, if we're not doing anything, then
I might go live and uh just to cook some
Muslims, you know, be on 2.0. All right,
so y'all stay tuned. I love you guys.
Thanks for sticking around. Uh, thanks
for praying for us. Um, man, you guys
are awesome. You guys are awesome. Keep
praying for us, man. And you guys see,
excuse me, you guys see Christ is king.
We are a royal priesthood and a holy
people and the wicked flee when none
pursue.
These dudes fleeing out here running.
Absolute cowards. Christ is king. Christ
is Lord. Christ rules. Period.
God bless y'all.
>> [laughter]